[Musique]
je vois la plus belle tous les corps du
modèle que je pouvais devenir
végétarienne j'attends de toi que tu
sois le plus fort mais pas trop quand
même tout le monde à table
cherry sort les poubelles comme d'hab on
a de grands projets comme da dans
l'avion s'est jamais non comme d'hab on
aimerait bien se poser comme d'hab
allez on va se coucher ça fait pas la
part la fois
[Musique]
bal à papa
voilà
mais qu'est-ce qu'il fait peur ici j'ai
moi qu'est ce que je fais
il est là le bonheur c'est pas l'heure
qui choisissent et christophe qui me l'a
dit et puis un jour meurent tu verras ça
va vite
et les vieux qui le disent de gens
indispensables et cimetières sont
remplis
comme d'hab on a de grands projets comme
dans la vie on ne sait jamais comme
d'hab on ne revient se poser et être
allé on va s'coucher ça fait pas la
passe là bas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
com
on a de grands projets dans la vie on
sait jamais comme d'hab on aimerait bien
se poser est est allé on va se coucher
ça aussi c'est la vive profite de la vie
tu verras ça va vite comme si j'avais su
j'aurais pas vrai comme ça non tout ça
c'est des conneries ça aussi c'est la
ville profite de la vie tu verras ça va
vite et si j'avais su j'aurais pas mais
comme salon tout ça c'est des conneries
ça aussi c'est la vie copie de l'avis
général va vite
les conneries
[Musique]
tout ça c'est lui donner
[ __ ] les balades ou et
j'adore
[ __ ] tu t'arrêtes avec lui tu devais
partir mon avenir je reste avec nous
il t'a que je suis fin reste avec nous
toute l'émission c'est une chance que ça
doit être ma chanteuse préférée je vous
dis la vérité
voilà j'ai pas peur de le dire et si je
dois blesser des gens sains
si je dois si je dois avoir les gens qui
m'envoient des colis b1 et ben hebert
écoutez moi je les recevrai dans la
gueule on affronte l'album mais fou
d'albums de bittar vraiment il est fou
mais j'ai dit non mais c'est quoi ce qui
fait que tu nous as fait sans déconner
j'avais l'impression d'être à la bar
mitzvah duty dames c'est la mairie c'est
quoi ça mais c'est quoi vite ac est avec
nous toutes les missions merci d'être là
vita en thèmes forts et bien sûr l'album
est toujours disponible et est nommé aux
nrj music awards bien sûr et c'est
normal et j espère vraiment tu vas
gagner francophone de l'année
kara les artistes les féminines et
francophones et cette année donc
forcément ouais les paramètres